>>> THERE'S A WHOLE FLEEOF
THEM.
THE U.S. NAVY FIGHTER PILOTS
CELEBRATING WHEN THEY WALKED ON
TO AN UNIDENTIFIED PILOT DASHING
ACROSS THE SKY.
BACK IN 2015, VIDEOS LIKE THESE
HAVE FUELED UFO EXPECTATION AND
QUESTIONS OF EX TERRESTRIAL
WORK.
AND NOW NASA WILL BE LOOKING FOR
MORE ANSWERS.
THEY ARE LAUNCHING A STUDY ON
UNIDENTIFIED AERIAL PHENOMENON
AND JOINING US IS SPACE AND
DEFENSE CORRESPONDENT KRISTIN
FISHER.
MY GOODNESS, THIS IS THE KIND OF
THING THAT BACK IN THE DAY YOU
WOULD HAVE SORT OF LAUGHED AT
BUT NOW WE'VE SEEN THESE VIDEOS
TAKEN BY PROFESSIONALS IN THE
MILITARY, WHAT CAN YOU TELL US
ABOUT THIS TEAM AND THE STUDIES
THAT THEY'LL BE DOING?
>> SO THIS NASA STUDY REALLY
JO
JOINS UP CONGRESS WHICH HAS BEEN
INVESTIGATING IT, THE PENTAGON,
WHICH HAS BEEN LOOKING INTO ALL
OF THESE INCIDENT, THE OFFICE OF
THE DIRECTOR OF NATIONAL
INTELLIGENCE, AND NASA, AND THEY
ANNOUNCED THIS STUDY LAST
SUMMER, AND JUST ON FRIDAY, THEY
DECIDED TO OFFICIALLY ANNOUNCE
THE TEAM, BECAUSE THE STUDY OF
COURSE STARTS TODAY, AND IT'S 16
INDIVIDUALS, THESE ARE PEOPLE
WHO WERE STON MERS, AFT
PHYSICIST, BIOLOGISTS, OBS
OBSERVE -- OCEANOGRAPHERS, FAA
FOLKS ON THE TEAM, A FORMATTER
ASTRONAUT, A FAMOUS FORMER
ASTRONAUT SCOTT PELLEY WHO SPENT
A YEAR IN SPACE, AND WHAT THEY
WILL BE DOING, IS THEY WILL BE
DIGGING INTO THE UNCLASSIFIED
DATA THAT'S OUT THERE, NOT THE
CLASSIFIED STUFF, THAT'S FOR THE
PENTAGON AND CONGRESS, BUT NASA
IS GOING TO BE LOOKING INTO THE
UNCLASSIFIED REPORTS, AND
THEY'RE GOING TO BE LOOKING AT
BETTER WAYS TO ANALYZE AND
CATALOG THE DATA THAT IS COMING
IN, NOT JUST FROM THE NAVY
PILOTS AND MILITARY FOLKS, BUT
FROM CIVILIANS, AND COMMERCIAL
ENTITIES, AND HOW THEY CATALOG
THE DATA, AND STORE ALL OF THE
DATA THAT IS COMING IN, WHICH IS
JUST A HUGE AMOUNT, AND EVER
SINCE IT HAS KIND OF RENEWED
INTEREST IN UFOs, IT HAS COME
ABOUT AND YOU KNOW BRIANNA, THEY
ARE GOING TO MAKE ALL OF THESE
FINDINGS PUBLIC, HOPEFULLY,
THEY'RE SHOOTING FOR MID 2023,
AND YOU KNOW, THE BIG QUESTION
IS WHY NASA, WHY IS NASA GETTIN
ON THIS AND IT HAS ALWAYS BEEN
THEIR JOB TO EXPLAIN THE
EXPLAINABLE OR ALMOST
UNEXPLAINABLE AND CONGRESS AND
NASA WANTS TO GET IN AND SAY WE
HAVE LOTS OF VALUABLE ASSETS UP
THERE, TOO, SATELLITES,
ASTRONAUTS, SPACE STATIONS, WE
WANT TO KNOW WHAT'S UP THERE,
JUST AS MUCH AS EVERYBODY ELSE.
>> SO FASCINATING.
AND THOSE PICTURES ARE
MESMERIZING.
YOU HAVE THE COOLEST JOB.
>> I THINK SO.
>> THANK YOU SO MUCH.
LET'S DISCUSS WITH RETIRED AIR
FORCE COLONEL TERRY VIRTS.
HOW DO YOU THINK THEY MIGHT GO
ABOUT THIS INVESTIGATION?
>> I THINK THE BIG THING FOR
THEM IS GOING TO BE TO GET DATA
WHICH IS SOMETHING THAT'S
DIFFERENT THAN WHAT WE USED TO
HAVE BACK IN THE 1950s WHEN
THERE WAS A LOT OF,
QUOTE/UNQUOTE, UFO SIGHTINGS.
WE HAVE RADAR TRACKS FROM NAVY
SHIPS, INFRARED CAMERAS FROM
NAVY PILOTS AND I'VE HAD A FEW
GUYS ON MY PODCAST THAT HAVE
TALKED ABOUT THE DATA.
THAT'S GOING TO BE THEIR FOCUS.
>> WHAT ARE YOU HOPING THEY
MIGHT FIND?
>> WELL, WHAT I'M REALLY HOPING
IS THAT THEY GET TO THE BOTTOM
OF IT, TO THE EXTENT THEY CAN.
EVERY SIGHTING CANNOT BE
EXPLAINED, BUT I THINK WE'RE
GOING TO GET A LITTLE BIT MORE
COLOR AND DETAIL ON EXACTLY WHAT
THESE THINGS ARE.
MANY OF THEM ARE PROBABLY JUST
DRONES OR ATMOSPHERIC SIGHTINGS.
BUT SOME OF THE CAMERAS AND
RADAR TRACKS THAT THE NAVY
FIGHTER PILOTS HAVE SEEN ARE
REALLY INTERESTING AND THEY
REALLY SEEM LIKE NOT NORMAL
AIRCRAFT TYPE OF THINGS.
>> YOU'RE A FORMER FIGHTER
PILOT, FORMER NASA ASTRONAUT.
I GOT TO ASK, DO YOU BELIEVE
ALIENS EXIST?
>> THAT'S A COMPLICATED
QUESTION.
I'VE NEVER SEEN THEM MYSELF.
IT SEEMS WITH ALL THE BILLIONS
OF PLANETS THAT ARE OUT THERE
YOU WOULD THINK THAT THERE MUST
BE SOME LIFE OUT THERE.
I THINK THAT LIFE IS VERY
COMPLICATED AND THAT SOMEBODY
HAS TO MAKE IT OR GET IT STARTED
JUST FROM A SCIENTIFIC POINT OF
VIEW.
IT'S SO COMPLICATED.
THOSE PLANETS AND STARS ARE SO
FAR AWAY, IT WOULD TAKE
THOUSANDS AND TENS OF THOUSANDS
AND HUNDREDS OF THOUSANDS OF
YEARS TO GET THERE.
SO I THINK THERE IS LIFE, BUT I
CAN'T BE SURE.
>> THIS PAST MAY, PENTAGON
OFFICIALS TESTIFIED BEFORE A
HOUSE PANEL THAT REVEALED THERE
ARE NOW CLOSE TO 400 REPORTS
FROM MILITARY PERSONNEL OF
IMPOSSIBLE UFO ENCOUNTERS AND
THEY SAY THEY ARE REASONABLY
CONFIDENT ONE OF THE SIGHTINGS
WAS THAT OF A DRONE.
BUT INVESTIGATORS HAVE NOT FOUND
EVIDENCE OF EXTERRESTRIAL LIFE
OR ADVANCEMENT BY A LOCAL
ADVERSARY LIKE RUSSIAN OR CHINA.
DO YOU HAVE CONFIDENCE NASA WILL
GET TO THE BOTTOM OF THIS?
>> I THINK THE INTEL AND DEFENSE
COMMUNITIES WILL TAKE A CERTAIN
ANGLE, THESE ARE PHYSICISTS AND
SCIENTISTS, THEY'LL TAKE A
DIFFERENT ANGLE AT IT, BUT THE
BOTTOM LINE IS, WE HAVE DATA
NOW, THERE ARE RADAR TRACKS THAT
EXIST, THERE ARE INFRARED TRACKS
THAT EXIST, THE FIGHTER PILOTS
WHO ARE REPORTING IT ARE NOT IN
THE UFO SOCIETY.
THESE ARE NOT THE KIND OF PEOPLE
WHO WAKE UP IN THE MORNING
WANTING TO SEE A UFO, THEY DON'T
WANT TO SEE A UFO.
I THINK THERE IS DEFINITELY SOME
LEGITIMATE STUFF HERE.
I'M SURE A LOT OF IT IS
EXPLAINABLE BY DRONES.
FROM WHAT I'VE HEARD ON MY
PODCAST, THERE ARE SOME THINGS
THAT ARE DEFINITELY
QUESTIONABLE.
THESE ARE REASONABLE PEOPLE THAT
ARE BRINGING UP THESE QUESTIONS.
SO INTERESTING.
THANKS FOR THE DISCUSSION TODAY.